[Music]
they always saw
methane as a problem something we don't
want to deal with
they never saw it as an opportunity
my name is junior mulan i'm the chairman
of frances del energy
my business is capturing abandoned my
methane in the former coal mining
regions and use it locally either as a
gas molecule or as electricity and heat
for the local people and the local
industries
okay so here you see
the former wellhead
where miner used to go down
and
mined for coal this has been sealed now
the environmental impact of methane
after our mining is closed is sadly very
high the global warming potential of ch4
which is the main components of
abandoned mymetan is 82 times higher
than the one from co2 so whatever
efforts we can do to avoid this
pollution
we should really strongly encourage that
[Music]
so the gas is pushing out of the coal
moving towards the atmosphere it's
coming through the pipelines
it's filtrated so that it's only pure
gas coming out of this system without
any dirt then it goes into this big
installation
what you're seeing here is a siemens
engine this engine is basically helping
us to increase the pressure so that we
can inject the gas into the grid
but before we inject the gas into the
grid as you know the gas has no smell
and you cannot see it you go through
this process to give it a smell so
that's for security reason you have a
leakage of gas you will smell it
so we go all the way
to the
end of the journey for this abandoned my
methane
is now coming to the distribution
network
to get into
the houses of the various people who
need it for
their home
eating and cooking system
i think our approach was uh quite
different in the sense that
we saw that we could develop local
energy production for local people
we have this historical terrill which is
this mountain of fines and behind that
you have the working class housing
and we want to be
providing
cheaper
local heat to those people so we are
currently finalizing an agreement with
the mayor of the city of avion to repeat
the success we had in between
here
so the heat generated by our site is
going straight to the bethune heat
district
we produce electricity and heat for
about three thousand houses equivalents
problematic necessities
that oppose
[Music]
is a fast growing company we are already
profitable and we are on track to reach
35 million of revenues by the end of
2022.
we are continuing our expansion in all
the countries in europe that have
decided to exit coal mining
when we got the
the asset it was complete wasteland and
so now we are slowly and slowly putting
it into a new mindset
transition is not something that is
happening overnight you need to be there
for the long term so that you can add on
additional resources and development for
the benefit of the local people